- mindset game iris
[Music]
give it man you guys 100% so what's you
know I would argue the biggest thing you
guys should be thinking about is
tripling down on how you got here
something I've been thinking about you
your bro and other like the kind of top
10 is everybody's now in a mad dash to
monetize as they should these are
remarkably big numbers I just don't
think you're going away and if you're
not going away my big thing now more
than ever is how do you go way more back
to the consumer that you like I think if
I heard today that you're doing a
two-hour Q&A live stream every single
day with your fans like juice with Jake
and it's like literally like just
drinking apple juice in the morning like
it's a different juice every morning you
know and just two hours like like real
real not even on an entertainment kick
just like [ __ ] GMA even maybe it's
we're gonna bring this up when you just
went on the old version of it and just
like how you doing
cool Sarah thank you for that yeah I do
remember like just real like as if you
were like with twenty kids that like of
love you've read it oh [ __ ] I forgot
about that [ __ ] post or like oh yeah
what has happened to like Sally Pants 49
she did have three million hope she's
doing well to me like what I'm feeling
right now
is this is the moment more than ever to
unmonitored rupal down on audience right
while it's under priced while it's under
priced attention get as much as you can
because the monetizing can be done at
any point and I just think everyone's
like you know again having empathy when
you're young you're on the ride there's
a lab like the the insecurities change
and Security's Drive so much the
insecurities now is can I be a
professional and drive it and build an
empire and be a businessman or woman at
that level you know what I mean it's fun
to watch so I think it's a very special
interesting time for you where that's
just one thing I would give a lot of
thought to I really would
I don't know this is like honestly I'm
giving myself advices I'm talking to you
like this is always the religion and
it's an interesting time yeah because
you become you bro you become the next
you become the next Brad Pitt let you be
it this is how it happens yeah like like
if you're 13 right now you're the
establishment and that new person that
popped last week is you yeah it's just
you wake up and it is it's funny to
think though I think you're gonna see in
the next year ago big game yeah we've
been on it forever like you saw what
happened last night last night was the
moment have changed I've been like we're
putting together a video right now I'm
glad to see you're not doing it that
means babbles making a good one right
iris Sat all right what's it about it's
just all this is what's great about foam
can film yourself
it's [ __ ] me in 20 14 15 16 17
talking about twitch and then I gave and
then I made I literally layin at 4:30
someone I'm like alright it happened
last night the crossover a moment here
come here comes people then ask me what
I think about it here's what I think
about it this is what I think of this if
you think these sports is going to be a
huge space like I believe so twitch
which plays in the eSports kind of realm
but in my opinion is dramatically bigger
than meerkat and periscope where they
have figured out their content very
easily which is it is now a foregone
conclusion
that millions of people will sip for
trillions of hours and watch other
people in my venture-capital behavior
eSports is now at the top I'm in love
with my thesis of eSports of virtual
reality and a 10-year window do you know
how many kids right now we're making
real Bank on Twitch playing video games
all day
are you giving any of your music or
jamming at all with any of the twitch
stars that's what I trade on right like
that's what's good about kind of how I
do what I do look the world is your
[ __ ] oyster my big thing right now is
when you're the king of the hill triple
down on it more look I would go back to
Jake Paul 0.1 where it was just about
the audience like as much as you can and
I know you can't go all the way back I
get it I get it
but if I can get you 70 percent back of
that 30 percent of what you're actually
doing now your hope your whole world
will be different audiences know just so
you know they will never be tricked
either you're doing it for them or
you're doing it for yourself when you
audit your [ __ ] last three weeks and
you think about how many hours you spent
on what's for you what's for them it
doesn't look pretty and it doesn't look
pretty for any of the a-list right now
in our world so cool and I driven by the
right thing I get it you did that first
you're trying to make your name and the
next thing I get it but I'm telling you
that's where the secret is hey guys it's
Gary Vaynerchuk this is the fifth pod
sessions my name is Arabella Ruby and
I'm an actress and a CEO of my own
company great to be here my name is rich
roll I am a recovering attorney turned
ultra endurance athlete Gabriel Anderson
I actually run our Vayner betta business
which was our small mid-market business
been working alongside of Gary for five
and a half 1 was six years now is like
who are you you know who the [ __ ] are
you and if you can't answer that
question honestly for yourself you can
pick a goal and you can be motivated by
Gary and take advantage of the tools
that he puts out in the world but you
might be climbing a ladder that's
leaning up against the wrong wall so you
really need to take the time to step
back and and really get to know who you
what is your design and what is it that
gets you out of bed and excited and if
you can be super honest about that and
like crack the you know veneer of denial
and all these things that hold you back
that is the path forward but if you want
to just leapfrog over that because you
think that's an inconvenience if then
you can go yeah you can chase stuff your
whole life but you're never gonna be a
fully integrated authentic person and
you're never going to achieve your
potential is never gonna be able to
share what it is that is most valuable
not just to yourself but but to whoever
happens to be paying attention to
whatever they're doing we're we're
Sameer there is what's happening no not
generally like what's happening right
now with the ads not like what's
happening in life I want a hack only
thing I care about
oh yeah is underpriced attention
underpriced attention that's all I give
a [ __ ] about like if you like you need
to play ten cents at a time a dollar
five dollars a thousand dollars I don't
care what it is underpriced attention
that's my video what state Thursday holy
[ __ ] isn't did it start
yeah I didn't fix my bracket [ __ ] I know
I felt good about it but not great big
what's happening do can you put up a
game there thank you how quickly can we
move what happened what happened what
happened what
what Royalle did what
against who viola beat Miami somebody's
losing them go get this Cyrus don't find
the person the happiest somebody went
there go find them now I think the more
interesting thing is that when somebody
comes that is exciting
yeah this is where all my kind of my two
sisters like it's kind of like my
favorite role in the hope is literally
my favorite part of my entire company
set up but I'm gonna I'm gonna ruin it
and set up something right here I'm just
going to try to give you some context
right like this is like a side wall it's
like where you come in actually I'm
gonna think of right from the entrance
and the organization all right so just
give me the context right so walking
here
there's my office over there so right
here I want to set up some sort of
twitch setup right this beer the I mean
to me again I'm gonna give you some
context because I know when I do these
kind of things systems it's hard so here
they are so to me it's kind of like like
somewhere here against this wall is what
I want to put the I mean this seems to
be the right place but am I thinking
about it wrong I don't know what keep
talking about it while I just think for
a second that's just I want to take out
air these desks this whole area and just
put tables for days we just put so many
anyway I don't know what else to answer
I'm building at which three all right
here I'm gonna play people in grade
school video games and I'll let you guys
do but I'm literally
you'll never beat me in double dribble
you'll never beat me in double dribble
let's see we'll see we'll see you know
the good news is I can't wait to make
the piece of content whereas with the
bubble hockey the deep [ __ ] flew in
here to take a [ __ ] beating we'll see
let's see to mindset game iris man
accountability
[Music]
about that just so about it right now
like so many of the emails I'm getting
and DMS and everything are just a
hundred percent about once you
understand that you're accountable and
it's your fault for everything you
become empowered because you realize
nobody's stopping you not your parents
not the government not your
circumstances when you could take full
accountability and it's your fault it's
[ __ ] amazing
then you're in control and that's when
you're not in control you know what's
your phone number and kind of energy
into that you're trying to fill a
business or I don't have to do my job
honestly honestly this is so cliche
where people trying to figure out their
time management and their allocation I
think people are mistaken judging
themselves when they're doing things
that aren't clearly monetizable because
sometimes they become monetizable like
when i hear your story right now if
somebody said bet the forum what happens
I think you've got a business in the
music business
four years from now it's just going to
take four years instead of 18 months
because you're spreading across three
things but that's okay because it's
early yeah that's the answer
so yeah 29 okay I would do all three you
know you've got your job to pay the
bills make it practical you've got your
business on the side you've got your
passion on the side one of those two
things prevail and that's becomes your
life where's Sameer no texting right now
at say I'm looking for mcdeere are you
doing anything productive I know
everything's good
where's Soph if she hustles I can't I'm
like I'm like I'm like working at 2:00
in the morning and then she's like like
she's hustling I know this should be the
show very soon here he's our boss now
direct I took listen you're my new boss
if I get competent listen listenmi Smith
if you get kind of if you get if you get
if I get confident with you I will make
shift for you on the spot good they're
going crazy of that basketball huh
people taking their bracket stairs who
want us to tell the truth because I'm
gonna look and mine is just a bad idea
who did not throw out the racket
everybody's good make sure you do that
yeah I would have washed my [ __ ] up the
team because that's the bouncers there
they don't know just yet
sandy Craig was like I'm coding over
here an algorithm on the [ __ ] he's
gonna win it you guys out of here is
this l-squared let's [ __ ] go Seton
Hall it's [ __ ] up iris this was a big
one central absolutely
god I'm so pissed I didn't go to JP
Stevens I love North her in high school
but like it's so weird to go like the
first grade to like eighth grade and
then bounce like that's what happened I
move we moved it was tough like I was
just like on the cusp of like taking
that transition with my crew and I
really did like bounced
I like left all my [ __ ] my locker like I
didn't tell anybody I didn't tell
anybody was moving yeah I wish what the
[ __ ] just happened
we're good I literally bounce like
literally nobody know and this was
pre-internet and like cream I get it I
get it
[Music]
[Music]